i'm
super excited today to talk about
how traditional companies across the
world
becoming technology companies using
apis delivering connected experiences
and accelerating their business
myself anil sagar sales engineer from
google
part of apigee team apigee is the
intelligent api management platform
from google traditional companies
becoming technology companies just like
google how
how are they doing it apis
who are these companies becoming
technology companies from the
traditional world
these companies are across the
industries
a traditional bank is becoming a
technology company
a brick and mortar retail store that you
see in the street
is becoming an e-commerce technology
company
an insurance company is becoming a
technology company
these are the few customers who use
apigee platform
to deliver their data and services apis
securely to their partners
to their internal applications to the
new kind of devices
that miti is talking about
we have worked with these companies from
last few years
precisely 14 years we learned a lot
about
api management working with these
companies
we built full api lifecycle capabilities
api management is not about api gateway
api management is about how you solve
your business problems
today how many of you use google maps
app almost every one of us use google
maps app
right but how does google maps make
money
anybody thought apis
just like google maps is exposing these
apis that is consumed by gosek
uber grab the companies the traditional
companies are exposing their data
and asset as an apis and finding new
business revenue channels
the capabilities that we built is
applauded
by the analysts recently
gartner positioned apigee as a leader in
the api management space
just not the leader we are the absolute
leader
highest in terms of execution for this
in terms of vision
what is the big deal why are these
companies using
apigee why are analysts rating apigee on
top of the charts
because apis will drive the evolution of
business
it's not about integration it's about
taking your business to the new fronts
metis talking about vision api
media is talking about the mls
and apis similarly how can you take your
data and services
and integrate with a google home
and integrate with other businesses
we see patterns when it comes to this
business evolution
how these companies are using apis to
transform the way they do business
the first pattern is about it
modernization and diesel transformation
you're using machine learning you're
using google dialog flow
but how can you connect to your data on
systems so that tomorrow
can you talk to your bank and do
transaction instead of using a mobile
app
can you talk to google home that talks
to your insurance company
can you able to renew your insurance
can you talk to google home and order a
product on your ecommerce store
the second pattern that we see is
increasing digital connections
and expanding enterprise boundaries
can your company go and talk to
cross industries today you're a bank
you want to go partner with e-commerce
players
you want to go partner with insurance
players how can you do that how can you
expose your services to these players
and finally creating ecosystems and
joining ecosystems
creating an ecosystem is always hard
it's not easy to get developer base to
use your apis
can you go and participate in other
ecosystem can you expose your data and
services as an apis
let's see real world examples how these
patterns are used by companies
across the world
pwc who haven't heard about pwc
no hands they are a tax consultancy
company
traditionally they offer people as a
service
to tax auditing and accounting
today they're a technology company
they had access to huge data patterns
now they use those data patterns they're
using
ml they built a cash flow ml api
that they're providing to the
enterprises using which
enterprises can able to optimize their
cash flows
from a traditional services company
they've grown to a technology company
offering
the ml based on the existing data
as a service through api they can able
to do it 30
faster they can able to reduce their
devops by
time by 20 percent apigee helped them
it's just not about apigee they're using
google cloud
they're using machine learning to
analyze that cash flow data
they're using google app engine that
talks to
the back-end system through apigee edge
api management platform
accuweather anyone heard about them
today you go to google search search for
weather in jakarta
one of the first results that you see in
accuweather
they're not only just exposing the
weather information in their mobile app
or in their website they're exposed to
media channels
they exposed to various third party apps
they use apigee developer portal to
publish their api documentation
to onboard their partners
they were able to get 24 000 developers
into their platform who are building
applications for them
integrating with different businesses
these twenty four dollar thirty four
thousand dollars
built eleven thousand applications for
accuweather
they get today 35 million api calls
every day each api call
is bringing dollars to accuweather
how they're monetizing their apis
just like google maps how does google
maps gets money
through google maps api when a gojek
calls google maps api to find a distance
between
two points google charges
go check similarly can your company do
that
can your company expose the apis
and make money out of apis apigee makes
it possible
interesting story about magazine loser
just like bukolapa an e-commerce player
in indonesia but they're little bit
different they haven't came from
technology background
magazine loser is a brick and mortar
retail store in the street that you see
they're not a technology company few
years ago
they were start the stock was dropping
because of the e-commerce competition
now they are able to successfully fend
off amazon you know the one of the
fastest growing brazilian market
they are the biggest e-commerce player
in brazil today
how they can able to do it apis
they started with 35 000 sku products
today they have 1.5 million sq products
2 000 merchants are selling their
products
on magazine loser platform
it's just not about that the e-commerce
platform that they built
they are exposing the entire platform as
an apis
so that the merchants can have their own
store
online store
they were able to successfully connect
the demand supply chain
they partnered with three banks they're
using banks
payment apis they partnered with telcos
they were they're leveraging telco
services
through apis again their stock
has skyrocketed 13 000 percent
in last few years a traditional company
a traditional beacon motor retail chain
have no presence online few years back
they were able to do it and expose their
services
their api their products just not only
on their website
to facebook to to mobile
to phone you can make a phone call
and purchase a product powered by api
so what are the capabilities these
companies are leveraging
what apigee platform provides for you
so let's take a look at the technology
stack of apigee platform
so we sit in between your clients
and your back-end systems your back-end
systems can be legacy
your back-end systems can be micro
services
your clients can be new kind of
applications like google home
or you want to onboard your partners
into your ecosystem
just like google does it today how
different people consume google
apis can you do the same
traditionally people think that api
management is api gateway
let me have api gateway in front of my
back-end systems let me expose my apis
my job is done that's what i t teams are
thinking about it
but that's not solving the actual
business problem
the business problem is this side how do
i
package my apis differently for
different teams
how can i expose my apis to different
partners
can i able to make money out of apis
can i build a new app where
my customers can able to talk to my
business through google home
for example a current reporting agency
in u.s
experience their apigee customer today
us customers can talk to google home
get to know what is their credit score
powered by apis
security is enforced by apigee edge api
management platform
mediation talking to dialog flow is done
by
apigee edge api management platform
so what do we offer primarily for
categories api runtime which includes
gateway
how many of you heard about istio hands
seo is the next big wave that is coming
to the industry just like kubernetes
that's a platform to manage secure
connect your micro services
every micro service is an api
how do you publish api documentation
how do you do enforce security like
oauth apigee helps
you do that the second is mediation
engine
as a enterprise you have different
systems with different periods of time
different security models it's not easy
to expose them
almost all the data is sitting inside
the great walls of china called
firewalls
how do you expose them to your partners
can you transform
existing legacy so based xml services to
new json services
so apigee helps you do the mediation can
you talk to the vision api
can you take your data combine it
make it as a new api can you do
orchestration apigee platform helps you
do that
great you built apis you secured apis
you are exposing it
your cto would like to understand which
partner
is bringing more traffic to me which
services are they accessing
where do i need to invest next quarter
can your devops team
find out before even an app goes down
apigee provides analytics and
intelligent contextual monitoring for
your apis
and importantly developer ecosystem
today there is a developer.google.com
where you can find vision api
where you can find speech to text api
where you can find google maps api
how about for your company for your
services
don't you want to have a developer
portal where you want to onboard your
partners
without any friction don't you want to
monetize your apis
and publish the api packages in
developer portal
where your partners can buy and bring
revenue to you
we provide developer portal where you
can publish api documentation
onboard developers publish
apis as a product that has a price tag
associated with it so that you can able
to make money directly
from the developer portal
what are we doing inside the google
cloud we are part of google cloud
you are using google cloud you are using
google cloud machine learning
you are building your backend systems in
google cloud now you want to expose them
to a google home app or a partner
we help you connect to different systems
we help you secure
your apis and services using the same
security that google
uses oauth we skill to
billions of api calls on an
average day apigee handles more than
three billion requests
on cloud with finance of availability
and we provide the connectors directly
to talk to
all the existing google features
so that let's say you are using big data
you are doing some analysis
now you want to connect that to google
home without writing single line of code
we help you do that
technology is great you have seen the
stories
but you need a strategy
to drive your api program
to convince everyone in the company
just like you are going to an adventure
you need a tool like compass right which
can help you point into the right
direction
we built a tool that will help you do
that
what does this tool will do your ceo is
thinking about network effects
your ceo is thinking about onboarding
new partners
your ceo is thinking about digital
transformation
your cto is thinking about modernization
moving from monoliths to micro services
using the latest greatest technologies
but there is an operational gap
how do you bring everyone on board what
is the key performance indicators
so using apigee tool you can able to
find actionable results
that can help you in your api program
again it will set a baseline it will
give you a digital score
where does your company stands in the
digital transformation
and the steps that can help you put in
the right direction
so it gives the three dimensions vision
are you thinking about transformation
business transformation or idea
modernization
what is your ecosystem strategy
do you want to go integrate with other
people
in other ecosystems are you thinking
apis just as an integration between your
mobile app website to the backend
or are you thinking as a strategic
products that you can take it to
different business teams
alignment who is leading your api
program from where it is coming is the
id team is the business team
how are you measuring the impact of api
program
is it number of api calls is it the
partner onboarding time
is the number of partners you want to
onboard your platform
just like accuweather who onboarded 24
000 developers
and hundreds of companies into their
platform
great you have a vision alignment what
about the execution do you have the
right team
and can your developers access your apis
within five minutes
so using this tool you can find
actionable results
that will help your api program
let's understand directly
from the leading bank in the region
how they are becoming technology company
it's a privilege to work with bank bri
let me invite
park registry who's the head of
digital center of excellence in bri bank
please give him a big round of applause
welcome thank you okay
uh thank you for having me here actually
i'm going to talk about
digital initiative in bank bri that that
is that we have been really working hard
in
2018 and if you
don't know about the bri uh i will let
you know
we are the biggest one of the biggest
bank in indonesia
or mac or market cap is about 34 billion
us dollar that is just uh in february to
2018
and our assets is around 83 billion
dollars
in just last year and then our net
profit
last year as you know it is around 2
billion
and not only that we have a lot of
branches
across the indonesia starting from
sabang to marauke
from west indonesia to east indonesia
if you call it it will be around like
two ten thousand branches
and not only that we also have a mobile
agent the mobile agent is
very very huge you know we are also i
think competitor of gojek
of doing the mobile agents we have
around 29
000 people for mobile agents
and and you know that our atm is also
the biggest in indonesia is around
24 000 atms having said that
we are now facing a great race in racing
of
fintech in the financial industry as you
know that
there have been like a market disruption
in the
financial industry especially for the
bank it really impacts us you know i
don't consider this
it's not impacting us but it is
impacting us
indirectly you know i've been
looking for the four areas is the
payment
lending and the compensation and also
the personal finance if you notice that
today's
what you try to lend money is maybe not
from the bank
but you can you get the money from uh
the fintech
let's say that from amateur or maybe
from one to one you know why because
it's really fast to
to get money from them it's just a
matter of this you know
but in conversation with us you may need
to fill up the paperwork that is
endless time and later you know it will
take like maybe a month or maybe two
months but after that
you see that is a long-waited process if
you try to get
maybe a kta or you know a business
without
uh you know argument and for the payment
perspective
in indonesia we do have a goal check
you you know that the copay is actually
a challenge for us
because they're starting doing the
payment industry which is
taking on market share eventually and
also
you know that we have like other
competitors like you know
like car dooku and maybe ferry transfer
the payment uh gateway
and also for the profile finance as you
know it that you have
we have actually competitors like arjuna
and genomics
but we need to work with those
competitors
at the end especially we're considering
the new technology
developments in ai big data and
blockchain and even the cloud
itself okay
so bri is actually doing the
digitalization
starting from the legacy the obvious
paper
and also the is very complex process and
it's like a long process
and now we in 2018 we do have we have
um two products in internal bri
first is myvli and the second is behind
spot or brief spot
the my bri is to help our
agent in the fields to operate with the
motives
while the b spot is for the microbial
micro lending
but what are the resources the resources
that we we see that there are like 30
percent to 40 percent increase in
all sales productivity and 80 percent
motivates
for micro loans under you know with less
than two days approval
so uh this is a
how do we actually integrate with the
partners
that we you know that we need to deal
with every one of them it's different
you know project or business model for
one of them as you know that we have
like the open api
you know in the middle and we have a
parties like all legacy breaking system
that connects to the open apa
and also the third party developers or
maybe the fintech developers and the
mobile web applications
and by the side the insight is that we
can weigh in our product offering
which is we also can monetize our
own api
and with fpg we we can see that this is
as of digital value chain
inside your bare eye so let's say the
customers will connect to the phone apps
of like tocopedia bucalapa
any other marketplaces and in the middle
you see that it will they will connect
with us with apg
or bri apa and then
in the back end the bank ai we actually
we can actually
expose the e-government and maybe pay
[ __ ] or e-roll
and also all credit scoring
so as a conclusion we can actually see
that
this is much more easier to collaborate
with third party or with our partners
compare without using the apg
so let's talk about the building engine
because this is
very special to us this is it will help
our digital transformation
and especially you know they're
considering that there are a lot of
engine building across the country so
how do we actually
find the best agent building for our
specific customers
that's why i think we can find it also
you we can
consume the google map api to actually
find the
nearest again building uh
at the certain cities something like
that
okay i think uh for conclusion
years ago we consider ourselves you know
just like a bank you know with a lot of
like
regulations you know as you know that we
are like set on company bank
and i think today we can consider
ourselves as a bank as
an id company with a bank license
and there are like two codes for me that
is taken
from uh brett king and michael corbett
banking is no longer somewhere you go
it's something you do
and we see ourselves as a technology
company with a bank license
i think that's it for me thank you
[Applause]
yeah so
uh you heard about the customer story of
bri bank right
you heard about how a traditional bank
is becoming a technology company
so we would like to open up for
questions if you have any
happy to answer them
any questions in the audience
again you can learn more about apigee in
apigee.com right
and keep us posted thank you thank you
so much